les mardis de la colère se poursuivent à
marseille devant l'hôpital de la timone
ils étaient une cinquantaine ce matin à
protester contre le passage du ter et
l'obligation vaccinale d'ailleurs 40%
des soignants ne serait toujours pas
vaccinées à face à un manque de
personnel d'éventuelles mises à pied
entraînerait des dysfonctionnements dans
les services hospitaliers et des
manifestants qui réclament également de
meilleures conditions de travail
nos directions sont de plus en plus
clair que au 15 septembre s'il n'y a pas
de vaccination aussi les agents ne sont
pas vaccinés ils vont être mis en
disponibilité sans salaire à la maison
et ne pourront plus travailler dont on
trouve c'est absolument scandaleux de la
part de ces directions et de la part de
l'état qui a mis en place cette
obligation vaccinale pour les personnels
hospitaliers et qui va s'étendre à toute
la population
on trouve ça scandaleux vu la gestion
qu'ils ont eue sur la première et la
deuxième vague notamment du coc vide
l'année dernière depuis le début de
cette épidémie ça avait commencé avant
mais là ça a complètement explosé c'est
un comportement de nos directions
qui absolument insupportable et qui a
provoqué une déchéance très très forte
et de plus en plus importante de
décoller donc une rupture de confiance
qui ce qui s'est fait de leur de leurs
propres responsabilités
voilà et puis au final aussi
quand voulaient contraindre les gens au
bout d'un moment vous en avez une partie
qui
réactionnelle
refuse ce genre de méthode refuse la
menace est donc alors qu'il était en
hésitation simplement d'hésitation à se
poser la question se met dans le refus